ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner and jelica Houston
good evening much of a film's power to
stir our imagination lies in the use of
sound whether it's the cry of a wounded
soldier or the soft flutter of a bird's
wings sound adds dimension to film and
is one of its most powerful components
this year's nominees for best
achievement and sound are Kevin
O'Connell Greg P Russell and Keith a
Westar for Armageddon
Kevin O'Connell Greg P Russell and peg
Cusack for the mask of zorro Gary
Rydstrom Gary summers Andy Nelson and
Ronald Judkins for Saving Private Ryan
Robin O'Donoghue Dominic Lester and
Peter glasses for Shakespeare in Love
Andy Nelson Annabelle Murr and Paul Bryn
cat for The Thin Red Line and the Oscar
goes to Saving Private Ryan
Gary ride scream Gary Somers Andy Nelson
and monnel judge
this is the seventh Academy Award for
Gary Rydstrom the fourth with Gary
summers and the second for Ronald
Judkins it is the first Oscar win for
seven-time Naaman
Andy Nelson
for a whole generation that has never
had to experience war saving private
ryan' powerfully and nobly demonstrates
the horror of what that is I came back I
have more thinking of Steven to do
Steven your eloquence with filmmaking
made this film an indelible experience
both to watch him to work on I want to
thank everyone at Skywalker Sound again
the people of Tadeo West Richard hymns
and a wonderful editorial crew paramount
DreamWorks Marty Cohen the entire sound
crews strived to make this film true to
the memories and the experiences of
soldiers and we were very proud to be a
part of it thank you
Thank You Steven thank you the Academy
two-time Academy Award winner and
nominee again this evening Tom Hank
37 years ago hey modest young man went
on a dangerous yet marvelous journey as
the world watched for just over four
hours he traversed the breadth of our
planet three times and most importantly
returned safely home overnight and in
spite of himself he became a bona fide
national hero recently at the age of 77
he again volunteered to circle the world
only this time the mission lasted nine
days and he needed to take his glasses
upon his return and in spite of himself
he once again became a national hero
proving that once you have the right
stuff you never lose it ladies and
gentlemen the man who twice harnessed
Godspeed Senator John Glenn
a person living at the beginning of the
century had to rely on the newspapers to
learn of the rest of the world with the
advent of the motion picture but that
was all very changed very much we could
sit in a darkened theater and be
enthralled by dramatic and exciting
stories of real people revealed on the
scoot on the screen and we found our
heroes heroes for who were once just
names in a dry history text suddenly
came alive and young people all over the
world were moved to say hate when I grew
up I may want to be like that
the remarkable accomplishments of those
ordinary and extraordinary people caused
us to seek within ourselves those
qualities have made them so special and
maybe their example made us a little
more daring a little more adventurous
and even a little idealistic